and j a adande did not exist when i was
at the madill school of journalism as he
does now and joins us here on the rich
eisen show as the co-host
of the dream team tapes podcast good to
see you jay
donde great to be on with you rich and
it really came full circle right because
uh you were gracious enough to host some
of our students on on our
deal explorers program when they came to
l.a a couple years ago
they came out and spent some time and
it's funny
one of the things i tell students
including our students is that
very little if nothing that we do now
existed
when we were in school so no there was
no directors for journalism at the deal
just like there was no podcasting being
done just like there was no
social media yes none of this stuff
existed so
but really the point i'd like to make is
that learning the fundamentals
if you master those you will be able to
adapt to whatever platform
is still to come because probably
whatever people are doing 10 years from
now
doesn't exist right now no question
about it no no doubt about it i mean
it was just basically go cover something
and then write it up as if it was an
actual newspaper but the washington dc
quarter that i
i had mentioned was real stuff like i
was working for real television stations
that contracted through the school
to utilize me on capitol hill in a way
for
my credit that they wouldn't be able to
spend money to have an actual
correspondent there in washington dc
and it was invaluable it was absolutely
invaluable the stuff that i did
and to be honest with you one of the
reasons why i went there is because
schefter did and i saw what he was doing
and and what he what became of him you
know and so
um pretty cool pretty cool stuff you
know
when i went to because i saw what he was
doing at the university of michigan and
so i went to madill and i saw some other
people
get through it so i wanted to get to you
know what adam schefter was doing quite
frankly
you know and for for the undergraduates
when we would do our internships
we didn't have sports options i got to
do some sports i was lucky i was at the
san bernardino sun
san bernardino california and i got to
do a couple laker and dodger games
but you couldn't do sports full-time and
now we have the opportunity for people
to do
full-time sports internships as
undergraduates in addition to doing
sports stuff as graduates so the world
has changed
a lot rich well look if there's anything
cool if there's anything i could do
you know i'm not just saying that on the
air you know i'll always be about it you
know
and and uh of course squash the hopes
and dreams of those that i fear
could take my job so that's i have no
problem doing that
well i gotta teach him the real world
stuff jay you know what i mean like
you know that's what i gotta do you know
what i mean i'm hoping to see that you
said it
on the air so i'm holding go back and
i'll rewind and replay this if you ever
try to weasel your way out of this
commitment
i will never do that um j.a donde here
on the rich eisen show i will read
sir from your most recent tweet about
your podcast
uh episode four of kobe lebron and the
redeemed team the godfather
hear how jerry colangelo took over
operations of usa basketball convened a
quote unquote meeting of the five
families you had me at hello on that one
and received an endorsement for coach k
forum from a surprising source what do
you mean by the meeting of the five
families
about the redeemed team olympic squad
jay so colangelo who we nicknamed the
godfather for this and if you know jerry
colangelo's
boss power it's an appropriate nickname
uh after he takes over
the uh basically usa basketball program
he wants to hear from some of the
the authority figures and some of the
most powerful and influential people
associated with the history of usa
olympic basketball
so he gets in a room jerry west
michael jordan larry bird dean smith
john thompson scotty pippen all these
olympic greats uh from the past and gets
them to convene so that's why i likened
it to the media of the five fans it's
very difficult to get all those people
in a room uh especially when there's no
financial stakes involved for any of
them
so um they they just basically have a
have a meeting and an idea session
brainstorming session on who do we want
to coach this team
what are the type of players that we
want on this team
how are we going to run this program
going forward so that was one of the
first things that colangelo did
as he took over the program and so um
you know we spoke with your your
colleague and co-host jack mccallum
uh last week about this but really
lingered a little bit more
on on the the original dream team that
he was there and around for
um just seeing these photographs of kobe
and lebron right now
just really strike me of how young
lebron is and how
kobe was essentially the to use the
phrase godfather of that team
as well um how much do you think rubbed
off on lebron
from this redeemed team and we're seeing
today now that lebron has taken on the
mantle in this role
uh a lot and and it rubbed off on a lot
of the other guys here we talked to
carmelo anthony hugh carmelo anthony he
was great about it
describing um you know how much
the kobe's work ethic and the dedication
i i really believe he taught
those guys what it takes to get to the
top
and he was a three-time champion dwayne
wade had won a championship with no six
but most of those guys
hadn't uh jason kidd uh
is still hadn't won a championship yet
at that point he'd been to the finals
but
so even he is really the veteran leader
of that team
i haven't experienced championships and
so kobe
showed them all what it was and sort of
my central thesis for this is that
they all benefited from being around
kobe and and seeing the dedication and
and what it took for him to get to the
very top and he's
at his peak at this moment in time in
2007 and 2008 when when he's playing
with team usa he
he led the league in scoring in 2006 in
2007
35 and 31 points per game and then in
2008 he goes on to win the mvp
so this is kobe in his prime age 27 and
28.
um and so they're seeing that and
they're seeing the the the fruition of
all of the work that he's put in and so
you get to see both the process
and the end result simultaneously it's
pretty rare that you get to experience
that
and the flip side was yes just the flip
side was that
kobe benefited from being around them
because he learned what it was like
to really be a teammate to socialize and
to be a part of the group to feel like
you belong to the group
and so that was his take away from it
and what about
this uh again this is the latest episode
of the dream team tapes podcast where
you can get anywhere right now coach k
we're waiting to hear and see what
happens with his duke blue devils over
the next few days about march madness
that starts next week
uh when you say uh needed a
needed an indoor did he need an
endorsement were were some of the
players like wondering why is coach k
coaching us did that actually at this
point
at that meeting of the five family they
hadn't picked the coach yet and so
part of it was a philosophical question
okay what type of coach do we want we
want a pro coach
do we want a college coach and what
would the argument be for
for having a college coach and again uh
there was a surprising i'll save the
mystery for the podcast but one of the
people that i mentioned
maybe one of the people least likely
that you would least expect to nominate
coach k
or to champion his cause for being that
the coach of the olympic team
um you know really comes out in favor
and that helps
convince jerry colangelo that shishevsky
should be the guy
um you know a sort of a a downer of a
phone call between
colangelo and greg popovich who he was
strongly considering for the role
helps tilt the the thing in favor of uh
suzetsu as well
so uh and he works out perfectly so the
next episode coming
out is really about coach k and how it
works and if you want to hear coach k
drop f-bombs and mf bombs
tune into the that podcast because he
just casually lets them fly
and um the one we just recorded actually
right before i came out with you guys
looks at what happened when they
they finally got together the closest
thing that we've seen to
to the dream team in o7 so remember one
of the things colangelo demanded in
order to get the program back on track
was he wanted a three-year commitment
from from the key players and kobe's
heard in 2006 so he can't play carmelo
and lebron
dwight howard on that 2016 chris bosh as
well that actually
loses in the semifinals of the world
championships in greece so they
suffer a setback and then 2007 is the
first time you have kobe
lebron playing together and so we really
focus on
okay how does that work how do these two
players the
the guy who's on the throne at the
moment and the ascending king and lebron
james
uh coming off his first trip to the nba
finals how did they work together
and jason kidd really played a big role
and sort of stepped up and said okay
they won't be there of you two leading
the team i'll step up i'm sort of the
third party the the neutral party
and they could run everything through
him and that's one of the ways it worked
was that it wasn't the two guys fighting
for control of the team
they said okay jason kidd you're the
leader and we'll just follow the line
behind you
love it and so people j adande here on
the rich eisen show
that uh hey you know uh wait a minute uh
mike shashefsky works blue he puts the
blue and blue devils well any anybody
who plays room will say that yeah
and then you also have to remember uh
who his college coach was uh back in the
day
you know at army he's correct and um he
worked blue quite a bit
uh despite wearing a lot of red in his
career um so
uh let's talk about the here now are you
concerned about the current lakers
chance to repeat yes or no
no i i think once they're they're
healthy they're they're fine uh
you know we've seen what they can do
when when they're healthy and motivated
and
so some of their that little slump
before the all-star break uh
they'll be fine they'll be fine they
probably just needed a little break
anyway
okay so um you're not concerned about
how they might match up
with a certain team that is continuing
to just amass talent
and get healthy themselves in brooklyn
that does not concern yourself now that
blake griffin is out there
uh adding to the nets
it the nets are in such an ideal
situation because
everyone slides down the slots so i
don't think you win a championship with
kyrie irving as your best player we
haven't seen a team win a championship
with james harden as your best player
but we know you can win a championship
with kevin durant as your best player
and if kyrie irving is the second best
player or
however you want to do it irving or hard
as the second best player
um that's a luxury and if blake griffin
now is
your fourth best player uh what a what a
great opportunity for him
um yeah they're loaded they're loaded up
we
still need to see if it can all work you
know i'm in the process of doing a
podcast
of showing how it worked with this group
but it wasn't guaranteed
how does it what does it look like how
does it work
can they defend well enough and
can teams come up with a great defensive
scheme remember the lakers they're
they're calling
card yep and and so
can frank vogel and coaching staff and
can the team
lock in in a seven game series um
when the pressure is higher can they
lock in and take away some of the things
that brooklyn wants to do
because i i put it this way i have more
confidence in lakers ability to take
away
take things away from brooklyn
offensively than brooklyn's ability to
take things away from what the lakers
want to do off that story so then i'll
give you a choice between the buck
sixers
jazz sons the team that's most likely to
crash this party is
which one j dante
utah
you know we have to give some credit at
some point that the thing is you have to
ask
historically which the team that wins
the championship has one of the six best
players in league and i'm not sure
utah's
best players qualify as one of the top
six players in the league
i'm not sure they'd qualify as the top
four top three players on the
features of brooklyn nets well they
didn't they they certainly didn't for
the all-star game selection
didn't even i don't even think top six
in the reserves they didn't even land
actually remember a couple years ago
james harden was the last guy picked
right
so so i don't think we can base our
rankings based on
on when guys are picked into all-star
draft notice our draft is so much fun by
the way i love that thing i enjoyed the
entire all-star weekend
quite honestly and you know it was a lot
more fun than you expected right and
steph and dame lillard in particular put
on such a great show yeah no i know and
by the way this is something you might
want to teach to your
uh to your students at the madill school
of journalism you just want what we on
the rich eisens show j.a
dante call you in higher register and
when you go higher register with your
voice you're saying something that you
need to go higher register to believe
like hey you know that was not a bad
weekend you're like
you i noticed you did that i'm more than
happy to be your higher register
adjunct professor that's what you are
the editor of higher register yes he's
created a new position yes and part of
and part of the power register is
convincing yourself
yes you've got to convince yourself you
got to go higher editors like hey you
know actually i think the suns have a
shot you know what i mean like that's
that's where you got to go in order to
believe what you're saying
and by the way also we can be part of
the curriculum or syllabus whatever you
want to put is
uh using the phrase with all due respect
to say something thoroughly
disrespectful
to inoculate yourself what was it that
lebron said
before he thoroughly disrespected that
the jazz players he said something oh no
slander i think it was no no slander
that's that's another version with all
due respect we just didn't play the jazz
back in the day playing video games so
you know
not even car malone you know i mean
that's what he said no slander is it
just another version of with all due
respect
again i could teach the kids i could
teach them well to use the phrase
it's up to you uh before i let you go
j.a adande we yesterday i know
i have no idea how we meandered on to
this subject
but we did uh lakers town or dodgerstown
los angeles is one
which one is it lakerstown you can't go
both which o'shea jackson jr did that's
not acceptable
i will not accept that which one you
have spent many many moons in this town
sir lakerstown dodgerstown los angeles
lakers town and i grew up there it was a
dodgers town
i'd say through 19 even up including
1988 but really the 2000s what they did
so
the dodgers went with that three decade
drought without winning a world series
and
and with the lakers winning five times
between
2000 and 2011 that that certified it as
elected
so you're saying when the showtime was
happening when showtime's happening at
the forum
but you know uh kirk gibson wins the 88
world series to cap a decade in which
the 81 strikes shortened season bob
welch is fanning
his fan and reggie and they win 81 and
they win 88 that's that made it a dodger
town even when magic was here is that
what you're saying
it was still the dodgers that magically
it was transforming in the in the legacy
of magic right one of the legacies of
magic is that it's now a laker town
but when they did the top the top la
sporting moments of
of the century kirk gibson's home run
was number one
um you know i don't think if you did if
you expanded now
20 years later i think a laker moment
would be you know maybe the kobe lob to
shack or something
but it that showed you that it was the
the dodgers still
mattered more through the 80s and i feel
like
it kind of they tied they both win
championships in 88
and maybe it was around a tie then but
but
the lakers had firmly taken it over in
the 2000s
thanks to the the three-peat and then
kobe winning two more that that
solidified it
j.a out there now what i mean i know
them both win championships in the same
month
yes last october so which one do you
think resonated more in l.a
i do you know what i i i i it's still
this is a lakers town i said it i didn't
stutter i i
like if you if you if you injected every
los angeles diehard fan with sodium
pentathol
and hook them up to a machine to
actually make sure that whatever one
percent wasn't
uh of lies was was detected they're all
laker fans
all of them would choose the lakers over
the dodgers to win certainly with the
dodgers having just won the world series
i know there's a lot of dreams come true
of people waiting
but you know like dodger fans have uh
are are
these days they wear the the mantle of
of
you know hard luck they're like the
scrappiest billionaire team of all time
and the lakers fans they wake up saying
well if we don't have somebody
generationally talented
that we deserve life's off you know what
i mean like that's the way i view it
having lived in los angeles since 2003.
i mean rich you've seen
purple and gold dodger hats you've seen
kobe bryant dodger jerseys
have you ever seen the equivalent with
the lake you don't see a mookie bets
version of a laker jersey
right you don't see a dodgeball even
though i love the blue laker throwbacks
sure but that's that's minneapolis laker
blue throwbacks right it's not an
homage homage to to the dodgers so
that's another indication you see a lot
more laker
branding on dodger stuff or laker
versions of docker stuff
then you see dodger versions of lakers
yeah i never saw an andre
ethi or lakers jersey
[Laughter]
wow without respect with all due respect
i should have said it before
successfully answered that question
richard there's no room
left for debate i agree look jack
nicholson is the the
the ultimate los angeles sports fan and
he's known as a laker fan and he's a
die-hard yankee fan
you know what i mean like i think that
to me that that's another open and shut
aspect of this thing but
i i still think it's los angeles laker
town and you know i appreciate you
agreeing with me and that's right
i remember when it was a dodger town i
remember when it was different it just
means i'm old unfortunately
okay and by the way that's also part of
the curriculum to tell the kids uh
at northwestern only have guests who
echo your sentiments
on your show to back it up and also if
you want the jim rome philosophy only
have people call in to tell you how
great you are
and then trump you know we could we
could get into trolling i mean i could
go deep
deep jay i could go very very deep for
you i i
i i hear the the syllabus forming as we
talk
with all due respect rich you know we're
doing everything on so many
thank you and congrats on the pot i
enjoyed a conversation with jack
mccallum let's do this more often jay
okay sounds great we'd love to be on and
talk some more and i'd love to have you
come in and talk to the classes as well
thank you sir that's j.a adande right
here on the rich isaac show
director of sports journalism at
northwestern i've got a program
epic i've got a syllabus i've got a
curriculum
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here